[Music]
you've come to a special place you're
here at a special time you have a great
opportunity in front of you we are so
excited to have you here welcome to
Stanford first time seeing the room my
name is Annabel okay I'm from Columbia
I cannot say I'm so excited to meet
everybody all the classes everything I
really like that GSB has a strong
culture of vulnerability and being
honest about who you are and being
authentic I think it's really easy in
the business world and the political
world to have this cookie cutter image
of who you are but a GSB people just
kind of open up about what this story is
what they really care about and that's
something that I'm trying to push myself
to do over the next couple of years so
that's why I wanted to come over all I'm
most excited to meet people and make
relationships that I hope will last my
whole lifetime most exciting thing for
me is to discover possibilities which
means to really understand the full
potential things that I can do here
people that I can make it's like the
energy just like the people the
opportunity is the excitement that
everybody has
[Music]